many of you have been asking the
question
what the hell happened to the Republican
Party
it can be difficult to notice changes
sometimes when those changes happen
slowly
let's take a look at how the Republican
party has changed over a longer period
of time and then talk about exactly how
it happened I am going to play a clip
for you here
of William F Buckley talking with Noam
Chomsky in 1969. now when you do a
progressive show there is no
conservative that you can put up as an
example that your your left-wing
audience in this case my left-wing
audience will agree yeah this is an
example of sort of like normal
conservatism and we disagree with
conservatism I understand that now I
know many of you will say David
Buckley's a loser he was a pompous
condescending clown okay Buckley had a
set of principles he argued them what I
would consider by today's standards
respectfully he stood for something he
engaged with people with whom he
disagreed
check this out this was one flavor of
conservatism and the Republican Party in
the late 60s and it lasted into the 70s
into the early 80s okay here's William F
Buckley talking with Noam Chomsky right
so but you also say that you hate
yourself for not having come to that
position uh earlier yeah I do I think
that was a very great great mistake well
I hope to give you a little Solace uh
the reason I do raise this and I rejoice
in your disposition to argue the Vietnam
question especially when I recognize
what an act of self-control this must
involve it does sure it really does I
mean I think that there's a kind of
issue really very well sometimes I lose
my temper maybe not no maybe not tonight
because as you would I smashing the
goddamn thing
would you say you say in the original
reason for not losing you say the war is
simply an obscenity a depraved act by
weak and miserable men including all of
us
including myself including every that's
the next sentence the same sentence
because you count everybody in the
company of the guilty I think that's
true yeah see one of the points okay so
anyway these are really interesting
debates and conversations
that was like what the Republican Party
one part of it right we can find wacky
examples as well but you could talk to
these people okay these did they
operated in something that approached
reality
here are some examples of the modern
Republican party not only do we have the
DC jail which is the DC Gulag but now we
have Nancy Pelosi's gazpacho police
spying on members of Congress spying on
the legislative work that we do gazpacho
police that's congresswoman Marjorie
Taylor green
here is another example of the modern
Republican Party
I have never been an escort for a
Senator Ted Cruz but but I will tell you
tonight it is the coolest thing I've
ever heard about yeah about Ted Cruz
there you go that's a radical republican
congresswoman Lauren bobert and then of
course the modern Republican Party
numerous categories were lower than the
world lower than in Europe and what look
and what take a look
right here
here's case death
oh you're doing death as a proportion of
cases I'm talking about death as a
proportion of population that's where
the US is really bad well much worse
than South Korea Germany Etc you can't
you can't do that you have to go by
you have to go by where look here is the
United States you have to go by the
cases the cases why not as a
proportional population somebody what it
says is when you have somebody that has
it where there's a case oh okay the
people that little from those cases all
right
that's a major contrast okay point I
think Point made now you could say well
but you know the modern Republican party
also has people like Mitt Romney in it
yeah how much attention do they get they
have been pushed to the fringes
so how did this happen and this is the
story that I've told before in fact when
when I interviewed Noam Chomsky we
talked about this story whatever you
think about Noam Chomsky I'm just saying
there's a discussion about this story in
that interview
and the path is more or less as follows
from the William F Buckley clip to what
I just played for you from from the the
orange Menace
the Civil Rights era
set off
a period of extreme uh instability in
the American right where many in the
American right did not like what the
Civil Rights era brought when they talk
about their world view we say it sort of
sounds like they want to go back to the
1950s that's exactly right before the
Civil Rights era which started you know
you could argue 58 or different people
would put it at a different point that
and the attempt to level the playing
field in many ways
started to anger much of the right where
not William F Buckley but others started
to get away from what we might now
called that principled conservatism of
of a certain point uh through the
Vietnam War
and into the Reagan Era we saw this
shift into what we might call more kind
of like meme politics from the right
uh actor Ronald Reagan
comes up with stuff like you know the
Cadillac driving welfare mom and and
starting to make these caricatures of
people hanging out living richly on
welfare
and on and on although Reagan was still
sort of reasonable compared to the
modern Republican party on something
like immigration but that was just one
step
we then go from Reagan and I'm
condensing the story to Bill Clinton
knocking out one term making George H.W
bush a one-term president which in 1992
significantly angered many in the
Republican party to then Newt Gingrich
becoming Speaker of the House in 1994 in
the 1994 midterms that was the next
escalation
it's not even really an escalation it's
like if you have
rhetoric on one side and policy on the
other
it continued the shift of the Republican
party from policy to rhetoric Newt
Gingrich in 1994
starting to develop the more cartoonish
social conservative starting to get a
little bit more detached from policy
then when you had the Clinton Lewinsky
scandal it escalated what we could
probably call Clinton derangement
syndrome Kenneth Starr's investigation
Etc and then it set the stage for the
first what I would call the modern kind
of like dumb Republican George W bush
now George W bush I'm sure personally
he's a nice guy and in some of the he
has been more thoughtful in some of the
statements he's made publicly since
leaving office particularly over the
last five to six years but George W bush
with his made up words and confusion
about foreign policy and all these
things ushered in the first kind of like
you know
light would intellectually lightweight
uh in the more Modern Way movement in
the Republican party then Barack Obama
won and it just Unleashed and even you
you took the bush contingent or
constituency and added some overt racism
and that was the next escalation and
then of course then ultimately we got to
Trump that's the path that's the 40 50
year path and it's really important to
understand it when we think about how we
got from William F Buckley to Donald
Trump right the guy who's staring at a
solar eclipse and saying what about
injecting bleach it's a sad decline
and it's unclear where the Republican
party goes next but it's good to know
how we got here